قبل ان يضع قدميه في اوكرانيا
هكذا قالها الروس لبايدن وموسكو
لواشنطن عليكم التعامل مع
البالونات والاجسام الطائرة
اولا. الصين تقدم حلا سحريا
لانهاء حرب اوكرانيا ترحب فهل
نجد مفتاح انهاء الحرب
الاوكرانية في ايادي اصحاب
العيون الضيقة والسبع المدهشة
اقصد بايدن يكمل رحلته الى
اوروبا بعد اوكرانيا. والهدف
ايصال رسالة مشفرة لبوتين.
اليابان تعطي وعدا لاوكرانيا
وتدخلهم بنوبة سعادة رغم ضراوة
الحرب القائمة. واشنطن وبكين
تتبادلان الاتهامات بسبب روسيا.
وبلينكن لن نرحمكم. وكوريا
الشمالية تطلق صواريخها يمينا
ويسارا. واذا اردتم هناك المزيد
هكذا قالها المجنون. الزلزال
يعود مرة اخرى في تركيا وسوريا
ومشروع مصري يثير قلق الكيان
الصهيوني. رسائل موسكو اللاذعة.
الحرب الروسية خرجت عن نطاق
اوكرانيا لتصبح حربا تطبخ على
نار هادئة بين وامريكا من جهة
وروسيا من جهة اخرى. لتظهر
الخالة سافر روسيا ماريا
زاخاروفا موجهة كالعادة رسائلها
اللادعة نحو الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون والى الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية. فابتدأت
بماكرون مذكرة اياه بمصير
نابليون عقب حديثه عن رغبته
بهزيمة القوات الروسية. واضافت
قائلة بشكل عام ماكرون بلا قيمة.
ثم اتجه نحو وكيلة وزارة
الخارجية للشؤون السياسية
فيكتوريا والتي تحدثت عن دعمهم
لهجمات اوكرانية على شبه جزيرة
القرم. حيث قالت ساخرة ان واشنطن
عليها التعامل مع البالونات اولا
ثم تتعامل مع روسيا هذه اللي
يقولون عليها بالجبهة. لنكمل ومن
جهتها واشنطن والتي اعلنت ان
الرئيس الامريكي سيزور جارة
اوكرانيا حاملا رسالة حازمة الى
بوتين مفادها ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي سيواصل دعم المجهود
الحربي الاوكراني مهما طال
الامر. ليتفاجأ الجميع بوصول
بايدن الى كييف قبل ان يصل
وارسو. والخبراء العسكريون
الغربيون يؤكدون ان زيارة بايدن
لاوكرانيا تاتي بالموت. وليس
بالسلام. وخلال زيارته الخاطفة
لكييف اعلن بايدن ان ستتلقى حزمة
مساعدات عسكرية جديدة بقيمة
خمسمائة مليون دولار وستشمل
انظمة اطلاق الصواريخ من نوع
هايمارس. لياخذ زيلينيسكي الامر
بشجاعة ويعلن انه تحدث مع بايدن
عن اسلحة بعيدة المدى والاسلحة
التي قد يتم توفيرها لاوكرانيا
حتى لو لم يتم توريدها من قبل.
هنا قالت الرئاسة الاوكرانية
للعالم. زيارة ليست رمزية ولكن
نتج عنها اتفاقات كبيرة. فعن اي
اتفاقات يتحدثون يجيب نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
ميدفيدي بان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن تلقى ضمانات على سلامته
قبل زيارته لاوكرانيا. وذهب
اخيرا الى كييف وهناك وعد
بالكثير من الاسلحة واقسم
بالولاء للنظام النازي الجديد
وتبادلوا التأكيدات بحلول بفضل
الاسلحة الجديدة والشعب الشجاع
حسب تعبيره. ليرد البيت الابيض
ان واشنطن اتصلت بموسكو قبل وقت
قصير من زيارة بايدن لاوكرانيا
لتجنب وقوع حوادث وفق وكالة.
فلنعد الى الحرب الاوكرانية. هنا
يعود الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي ليؤكد
بان القوات الاوكرانية لن تدافع
عن مدينة باخموت باي ثمن وليس
لاخر جندي مبررا ذلك بانها ليست
مدينة كبيرة للغاية. ومن الموت
والمعارك الى السلام والمفاوضات.
حيث اعلن وانجي رئيس مكتب هيئة
الشؤون الخارجية في الصين ان
بلاده ستقدم اقتراح سلام حول
الحرب في اوكرانيا مؤكدا على
ضرورة التشاور مع اوروبا حول
مستقبل اوكرانيا. والاتفاق حول
اي مبدأ يجب اعتماده للتوصل
للسلام لترحب المانيا بهذه الخطة
الصينية. فيما ردت واشنطن على
المبادرة الصينية لانهاء الحرب
في اوكرانيا على لسان وزير
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
الذي قال ان مسألة الحوار مع
روسيا متروكة لاوكرانيا. فهي
قادرة على اتخاذ القرار الصائب
بشأن السلام مع موسكو وفق
تعبيره. اما اليابان فانتقلت لما
بعد السلام. حيث اعلن رئيس
الحكومة اليابانية فوميو كيشيدا
ان ستقدم دعما ماليا جديدا
لاوكرانيا بقيمة خمسة مليارات
وخمسمائة مليون دولار. وذلك
لاعادة اعمارها. فلا كرامكم يا
هؤلاء هل تعلمون متى ستنتهي
الحرب اساسا لتعيدوا اعمار ما تم
تدميره؟ لكن ما هو اخطر من كل
ذلك هو اعلان التليفزيون الحكومي
الروسي. ان الولايات المتحدة
اعلنت الحرب على بلادهم وذلك على
اعلان امريكا عن دعم اوكرانيا في
شن ضربات على شبه جزيرة القرن.
قائلين ان واشنطن تجاوزت الخط
الاحمر بذلك وعلينا الرد وفقا
لذلك. وعلى سبيل التوضيح فقط هنا
وزير الخارجية التركي يؤكد ان
تركيا لن تنضم الى العقوبات
الغربية المفروضة ضد روسيا. فكيف
سترد واشنطن? الصين. الامريكان.
شرقا وغربا وشمالا وجنوبا تهاجم
الولايات المتحدة الصين. ومع كل
حركة صينية ومع كل قول وفعل صيني
تظهر واشنطن مجددا. هنا نائبة
الرئيس الامريكي تهاجم الصين
وايران وكوريا الشمالية حيث
اعتبرتها متورطة بدعم روسيا في
الحرب الاوكرانية بينما قال
مسؤول السياسة الخارجية الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل ان تزويد روسيا
بالسلاح من قبل بكين خط احمر
بالنسبة للاوروبيين وهم يقظون
لذلك بحسب قوله. لترد بكين ان
نظرة واشنطن لبكين خاطئة جدا.
وان الصين تسعى لمنع وقوع حرب
نووية تحت اي ظرف. ليعلنها
الناطق باسم الخارجية الصينية
وانج بوينج صريحة بقوله ان
الولايات المتحدة هي التي ترسل
الى ساحة المعركة دونما توقف
وليست الصين. ليأتي الرد من وزير
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
الذي قال انه ستكون هناك عواقب
حقيقية ستلحق بعلاقات مع الصين
في حال توريدها الاسلحة الفتاكة
لروسيا مضيفا انه ستكون لدى
الصين مشاكل حقيقية في العلاقات
مع عدد من الدول الاخرى. فعن اي
عواقب وعن اي مشاكل حدث. وهنا
تظهر الصين تخطيطها للمستقبل
جيدا. فالطائرات المسيرة الصينية
لا تزال تدعم روسيا في اوكرانيا
وبعض هذه المسيارات يصل الى
القوات الامامية باوكرانيا من
موزعين روس اشتروها من شركة
مقرها الصين. لكن المفارقة ان
هذه المسيارات لا تعمل فقط لاجل
الضربات الروسية ولكنها تعمل على
جمع المعلومات لبكين بالتحضير في
المستقبل وفق. فيا لدهائكم يا
اصحاب العيون الضيقة. الاحداث
والتطورات. اطلقت كوريا الشمالية
صاروخين باليستيين قصيري المدى
باتجاه البحر الشرقي بعد يوم
واحد من اجراء كوريا الجنوبية
والولايات المتحدة تدريبات جوية
مشتركة شملت قاذفة وهذه
التدريبات كانت اساسا ردا على
اطلاق كوريا لصاروخ باليستي عابر
للقارات. لتخرج شقيقة الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي كم جونغون وتحذر
من ان بلادها تراقب عن كثب
تحركات واشنطن وسول لنشر مزيد من
الاسلحة الاستراتيجية الامريكية
في المنطقة متعهدة باجراءات
مضادة موازية. تحدث الجيش المصري
في بيان اصدره حول ارساله
مساعدات الى سوريا وتركيا عن
ميناء العريش البحري ومستقبله
الواعد والذي شهد تطويرا كبيرا
بكافة منشآت وارصفته خلال الاونة
الاخيرة. بينما كانت وسائل
الاعلام العبرية قد ابدت قلقها
من الميناء بعد تطويره لانه
سيكون منافسا قويا للموانئ
الاسرائيلية المطلة على البحر
الابيض المتوسط. ضربت هزتان
ارضيتان جديدتان ولاية هتاي
جنوبي تركيا بقوة ستة فاصل اربعة
وخمسة ثمانية درجة. وشعر بها
سكان سوريا ولبنان وفلسطين
والاردن. ليعلن عمدة مدينة هاتاي
التركية عن وجود مواطنين عالقين
تحت انقاض المباني التي انهارت
جراء الزلزال الجديد في المدينة.
قبل ذلك اعلن وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن خلال
زيارة لتركيا عن مساعدات اضافية
بمائة مليون دولار لاغاثة منكوبي
الزلزال. اعلن التليفزيون السوري
ان الرئيس بشار قام بزيارة عمل
لسلطنة عمان التقى خلالها جلالة
السلطان هيثم بن طارق. بتجهيز
قاعدة جوية حاولت اخفائها عن
اعين الرادارات والاقمار
الاصطناعية تحت الجبال. ايران
تستعد لتسلم المقاتلة الروسية
سوخوي خمسة وثلاثين بحسب نيويورك
تايمز. موسكو ترسل رسائلها
اللاذعة وبيض يستقبلها وهو في
اوروبا بينما تنشغل واشنطن
باطلاق رسائلها نحو الصين وكل
يغني على ليلاه.